you
hello and welcome to part two of machine
learning and pattern recognition for use
with stocks and forex trading now you
might not realize it but you've actually
just made a huge accomplishment already
and that's that you're viewing part two
you look at a lot of series on the
internet especially tougher ones it's
usually at least a 25 40 percent drop
off between part 1 and part 2 right so
you've already taken the initiative and
you're already ahead and probably what's
going to turn out to be of at least 25%
of everyone else
so congratulations on being serious if
you continue to voting sometime soon
you'll be in that top 1 to 5% and you'll
have some cool new skills and also to
give you a bit of a teaser you're only
just a few videos away from coding
pattern recognition they'd find
something like this this blue line is
the patterning question and all these
other lines are historical patterns that
followed a closed pattern to this one
and then what we'll end up doing is
predicting the future results based on
these past pattern results definitely
something to be looking forward to and
that's really only a few videos away
from here but the first thing that we
really want to do is go ahead and plot
out the data that we have so we can
actually see what we're working with and
see what what our goals are also be
useful just to get comfortable with Matt
plot libs we're going to be using that
so we're going to run through just
opening up his data and looking at the
data that we have first so we're going
to need a few imports and that's going
to be import matplotlib and then we're
going to go ahead and import some other
stuff even though we've imported the
full matplotlib we also want to import
various things as specific things so
we're also going to do import matplotlib
pipe lot as PLT import Matt plot Lib dot
ticker as and actually you know what we
don't even really need this well we'll
use it I suppose as M ticker and then
import matplotlib dates as M dates
finally we're going to import numpy as
NP now we're going to do a function is
going to be graph raw FX
and under here we're going to have a
numpy open up this text file and create
an umpire array for us so we're going to
say date bid-ask equals and P download
text so this is going to load up any
text file you have it can also do arrays
even though it is called load text and
the text we want to load up is going to
be gbp/usd 1b txt so if you got those
files that I got or you got you can
download from syntax calm if you take
the zip unzip it and there's two there
should be two text files in there one is
gbp/usd one day and one is gbp/usd one
month
make sure both of those text files are
in the directory right so in the same
directory as this script so not the
folder but both text files so if you
just have the folder it's not going to
find it so you would need to put the
folder in front so just keep that in
mind I'm going to say unpack equals true
and the delimiter of this file is a
comma and the converters this is so we
can convert a date stamp to plotting
dates and that's going to be the zeroeth
element so the first element in there
and so let me just pull up the file real
quick this is our this is our gbp/usd
one day text file so you've got the date
stamp and then bid-ask and here we can
see year and then oh five is the month
oh one is the day and then hours minutes
seconds so we come back over here and
our converters is going to be the zeroth
element how do we want to convert that
we're and use M dates and then we're
going to use STRP date to numb so strip
date to numb but it's STRP no I and then
in parentheses you give it the format
that this is in and you do it with
percent and then a character that
denotes whatever that is
so first we'll do percent Y that's for a
full year then we do percent lower capes
percent not a Sun % m percent day so
month day in number format percent
capital h4
hours percent capital M percent capital
s and that's the whole thing if you've
had dashes or something in a date you
would also put those in there but again
we don't really have that it's just a
straight stamp so that's the conversion
that we must make oops
and come down here now the next thing we
want to do is plot this so we're going
to define the figure that we're going to
plot on to so if a equals plot dot
figure and our big size will be ten by
seven next we're going to do a x1 equals
PLT diet subplot two grid and within
here the grid we'll make is just a forty
forty sighs we'll start the plot at the
zero zero
Andros family for 40 and colspan
also equal forty if I'm going too fast
at this point for you guys as far as
defining how to make this chart then I
highly suggest you check out the Python
charting tutorial I've got a whole
series on all this stuff and it goes and
way further depth than this so if you do
feel like you're lost I highly suggest
that otherwise just kind of copy what
I'm doing because honestly this part is
not the main part of this series we are
just trying to display the data and we
will continue displaying data but this
isn't really integral to the entire
understanding of machine learning next
the next thing we want to do is we're
going to go ax wound up lot what do we
want to plot we want to plot a date and
then we want to plot the bid and then
also x1 up fly and we want to plot the
date date ask and then what we want to
do is format the x-axis so it's in like
date format right so X 1 dot X X YZ dot
set underscore major underscore
formatter and in parentheses M dates dot
capital dat e capital F
RM attr and that date format now you can
choose anything you want so let's make
this date a little bit prettier than it
wasn't on the first time around so %
Capital y - % lower em - % lower D space
% capital H : % capital M : % capital s
and we've closed everything off already
next the other thing we're going to do
is we'll say plot and actually when I
touch that let's do guilty grid true and
PLT - oh it's going to be kind of an
ugly looking x and y-axes t teks ticks
but you'll get what I'm saying in a
minute so let's just bring this up and
so run it after you've saved of course
and you graph raw FX hit enter hopefully
no errors and we got date formatter L we
misspelled with a date formatter we put
3 T's in there so let's fix that real
quick save it run go again oops P on
that again hopefully y'all didn't typos
date formatter
there we go it should pop up for you
guys now and here is the data there's a
couple of things that are just kind of
ugly about this data right you've got
the date stamps are kind of running over
each other and the values over here are
kind of being like converted because
they have a lot of zeros and them right
stick data and this data goes way past a
pip right I think it goes to places past
a typical pip so anyway this is our data
this is a one day of bid ass tick data
the only really thing I wanted you guys
to see is that it's you know we've got a
fairly volatile day and overall at least
on this day the data is rising but I
believe on our / true overall we could
bring up that data and I believe overall
and for the month of May it was actually
falling I got this error because it
never
we misspelled date formatter anyway
that's the basic chart that's the basic
data that we're going to be dealing with
and one of the interesting things about
bid-ask let me bring it back up again
real quick as you can see the gap or
this what's known as a spread and you
can almost seem pretty much every time
the spread gets wide right it's either
going to fall or go up right volatility
is you know pretty much attracted to
that spread which makes sense right if
if more people like less people are
willing to sell and that gap starts why
not well it's probably the case that the
stuff is going to go up or down
same thing when it's crunches up right
like here you've got scrunch up and like
there's really no gap here because
everyone's like chasing it right so
there's also some pretty cool stuff that
you can do is spread however we're not
really going to be dealing with spread
at least in the initial videos we're
going to be dealing with price change
but the option is there for spread in
the next video I'm going to show you one
more thing about spread and then we're
actually going to continue on moving
away from spread or at least moving
without spread but spread is definitely
something you'll want to consider in the
future if you do decide to go down this
quant trading route so anyways that's
going to include the second video in the
third video let's we're going to at
least show you a few more things about
charting and we'll put up an interesting
graph with spread and then from there
we'll begin working on some patterns
setting up those and then the Machine
recognition of those patterns definitely
some cool stuff to look forward to if
you're not subscribed I highly suggest
you subscribe not going to release the
series all at once so they'll just be
coming out as I end up making the videos
so if you're subscribed you should get
something in your email or something
that tells you that hey I've got another
video or you can just keep checking back
anyway that's going to include the video
as always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support and subscriptions and
until next